I saw a picture of you with your husband
and he is quite tall he is as Andy said
you are less tall but there's quite a
height difference between you two do you
get I mean what's the reaction when you
to skip down the street together two
people and we do skip and people I have
to say we get a bigger reaction from
short guys short guys get really pissed
off they kind of give us a look like
stick with your own kind we have like
these short guys who live in our block
it's a group of short men they shop when
I honestly it live in fear that they're
gonna throw like a brick through our
window just to send a message this this
discrimination we're shorter people want
other shorter people to stay with
shorter people yeah we get the I yeah
get the I from the gap kids Wow
or were you uh I mean are you someone
that used to get intimidated you get
intimidated easily there are certain
things I get know who scares me terribly
a 13 year old girls scare me so that day
I am so petrified of them hey why are
you scared of 13 year old at that age I
was I was made fun of a lot I didn't
have a boyfriend at that age and I so
whenever I see like a group of 13 year
old girls I so badly want to be included
by them then like we were at a Japanese
hibachi restaurant recently no no this
is you and your husband be my Tahoe and
we're sitting at a table and they sit us
with this birthday party of
thirteen-year-old girls and I saw my
husband like looking like you're you
gonna be okay right and we sit down with
them and I get this involuntary physical
reaction whenever I'm around
thirteen-year-old girls that I'm trying
to prove to them I'm cool and so I just
start bawling my husband like making out
with him trying like to show like look I
have a boy when I have a man but I'm
doing it in a weird way where I'm like
making out with him and kind of giving
them the eye like yeah you see this I'm
cool and then so pervy it's why I was
made fun of it and okay these 13 year
old girls maybe shouldn't be seeing that
no they shy could be arrested may have
been in violation of a local ordinance
yeah it's possible there I mean I was
trying to to be included in their group
which is not gonna happen cuz I'm the
weird married lady who's like making out
with her husband at the bocce and I
heard them at the end say something like
hey did you guys want to go to Pinkberry
and in my like making out session I
heard this and I was like I just wanted
to be invited so bad
terrible and then the roving gang of
little guys are like that's it crashing
through the window